for anybody who is thinking he's like oh
i might do a startup or i might do this
i'd say unless you are absolutely
ready for it to take over your life and
unless you are
have the you know enough passion for it
don't bother i would say
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
and is sponsored by leumitech hippo
insurance touring
upwards labs and hillel at stanford we
have with us today zoe desmond the
founder and ceo of frollo
zoe is the founder and ceo of frollo the
first community app of its kind for
single parents
the idea for follow was born out of
zoe's own struggles with loneliness and
isolation when she became a single
parent
and found it very difficult to find and
connect with other like-minded single
parents
the frollo app is now a year old and has
20 000 members across the uk and ireland
2021 is said to be a busy year for
follow with plans to expand into new
territories and launch a frollo dating
offering zoe desmond thank you for being
on my show how are you today all the way
from london
i am in london it is absolutely freezing
in london at the moment so i don't know
what it's like where you are but it's
probably a lot warmer
oh well i'm in tel aviv right now and it
is a lot warmer it's still cold but
definitely not as cold as london the one
time i was in london
it was when it was freezing freezing
cold and i'll never forget it and so
that every time i hear london i think of
that but other than that beautiful
beautiful city and zoe i i want to hear
about your journey i want to hear about
frollo about you know
single parenting and why there is a
market
for you know this this you know finding
the common ground through social media
and through communication
but even more than that i want to go
back to your work with charity
uh you're you've been involved with
quite a few organizations and
tell me a little bit about what your
what what you've been doing
and a little bit of how that journey led
you towards frollo
and so well going back to the the
charity i was working with elephant
family when i when i first moved to
london
um which i think was about 13 or 14
years ago now it's easy to lose track of
of time but
i worked with the charity called
elephant family and
who work on uh raising money for the
endangered
asian elephant and we put on a
a big event called elephant parade
london
they do them all around the world where
um a bunch of
life-sized painted elephant sculptures
are auctioned off
uh for charity and their each elephant
is painted by a different
um you know artist or designer
and and then yes so we raised 4.1
million
and and that at that event in 2010
and which was amazing and i think i i
think what i
loved about working there was
that you know it kind of connected me to
purpose which is always really really
important for me
i need to absolutely feel like in order
to feel kind of
connected to what i'm what i'm doing it
needs to feel purpose-driven
i need to feel alive i need to feel like
there's there's a reason to it
otherwise it just doesn't work for me
but um so i loved it and it was a steep
learning curve
it was very much even though it was a
charity it felt like a startup
it was very much a lifestyle working
there there were times when we were sort
of
in the in the office till one o'clock in
the morning sort of getting ready for
elephant freight london but it's
when you have that kind of shared goal
and that energy and wanting to
really create something and do your best
because of the
meaning behind it and what you're
setting out to achieve and then
full of you know a really cool thing to
to work on as well because of the kind
of creativity involved
and so that was amazing and then i
and then i went on to um to work for
another
and non-profit organization called the
irish youth foundation
where i was fundraising and organizing
events for a bunch of different
charity organizations and again the kind
of common thread
is being connected to purpose sort of
you know um yeah being kind of
creative i suppose there's always been
an entrepreneurial
sort of part there happening there
and and then after that i
a friend and i decided that we we wanted
to create a startup
so we at a tech startup so we started
working on this idea that we had
and we loved the idea of having um
an online kind of members club which
connected
members via an app to classes
in the areas of body mind and social
around london
so we were just feeling quite uninspired
by
you know just sort of when you're kind
of
just in this life of sort of going out
for drinks going out for dinner
you know and we kind of wanted to find
like where are the cool advents
where the sort of ted talk type events
where are
you know where they're you know where
can you do kind of
ping pong classes but have a few drinks
with people at the end working
you know where you know just just just
different
different interesting and things to do
and ways to meet people
so we started um working on
on on this and bringing in different
okay it was it was i don't know if
you've come across class past
but um yes this yeah
so it's kind of like unused inventory so
that was the kind of idea
so we we went on about that we got to be
the testing
and then at that time i was literally
just about
to give birth and so
i at that stage sort of handed it over
to and that my kind of business partner
at the time
and said you know what you run with this
we were kind of having a different
idea and what the best way to take the
business was forward at that stage
i was going off to have a baby i felt
like it wasn't right for me to try and
have one foot in the door there and then
trying to be
a mother at the same time so so that was
that
and then i thought well that was a
really interesting experience i learned
a lot
i didn't see myself kind of you know
venturing down that path again i sort of
went and
became a mother and this was five years
ago
and and then a year later
and my relationship broke down with my
son's father
and i became a single parent
i have had no experience with single
parents and
i became one and i suddenly felt
completely sort of isolated
and alone and i didn't know because i
didn't know any other single parents
there was kind of almost like a shame
attached to being a single parent i felt
like i couldn't be the best mother
i wanted to be for my son because i was
finding it so tough and and
yeah it was kind of like felt like the
elephant in the room a lot of the time
as well
and and so i really craved connecting
with other people in the same situation
because i just wanted to talk to
somebody who could i you know understand
and relate to what i was going through
emotionally in terms of you know being
up at three o'clock in the morning with
a sick
child and not having anyone to kind of
share that load and
you know all of this i wanted somebody
who could understand and i wanted
i wanted other people who were free at
the weekends when i was to
to have play dates with to go for sunday
lunch with to have a glass of wine with
right and who might be around when my
son was with his dad
you know so i started to kind of think
about this and i had this vision in my
head and the more i thought about it the
more it sort of gave me hope
and i started to cling on to that hope
so then once i started
looking for a way to do this obviously
by taking to google
as you do and looking up you know
where you know single parent communities
i was very surprised and frustrated to
see that i couldn't
find a way now there's tons of facebook
groups there are
forums there are different things like
that but none of them
kind of none of them gave me a way
to easily connect with like-minded local
single parents in my area
and you know people who were like me
same age as me
with kids the same age instead the
forums that i found were a lot of
you know people bashing their ex and
saying kind of negative things about you
know
the other parent and that was not what i
wanted
i wanted i i have to i have to ask you
to explain to me something how
is it i mean you started follow about
three years ago right a little a little
short of three years ago
and you're you know it's so it's 2017
and you know the social media has been
around for at least 15 years at that
point
and you know with divorce rates being at
about 50
globally you have a ton of single
parents and the feelings that you're
that you're articulating here there are
difficult feelings they're difficult
emotions and we know that people
adopt consumer behavior when they're
faced with emotional decisions right
you know marketing you buy the most the
more expensive bottle of wine at the
supermarket because
the marketing branding is is changing
the way your
your emotional state so how is it that
how is it that there wasn't a good
solution
until furlough came about to this whole
population
of of amazing potential consumers
i i honestly don't know but the amount
of times
like frollo is p people people often say
to me oh my god it's such a brilliant
idea
and i say no it's such a simple idea
it's not a brilliant idea
it's just insane that it wasn't done
before how has this not
been here and also a ton of people have
said to me
you know single parents have said oh i
had an idea like that and i wanted to do
it and
i guess like probably a ton of single
parents have had the idea and i'd say
the thing about being a single parent is
you don't have a lot of time
on your on your hands and life is hard
and you're just trying to get through
day to day and you're and you know so
i think maybe i am
kind of yeah i was extremely determined
and i think the the the little bit that
i kind of
that that the small bit of exposure i
had i suppose to
the kind of you know startup idea i'd
been working on before
helped me not be completely blind to
what i was walking into and
and yeah and to be honest with you it
absolutely kind of working on
working on frollo and kind of having
that hope and that vision
got me out of my own kind of hole at the
time so
um yeah but it's it's it it is a very
simple kind of idea there's nothing
there's nothing genius about it so it's
it is it is absolutely strange
to me that it hasn't been done before
and
so the decision to do it locally in the
uk
uh and ireland i'm guessing is is
primarily due to your geographical
location
and your knowledge of the population
that is there right and your access to
those first customers yeah yeah exactly
so i started well
kind of what happened was i started
working on
on got an agency to start working on the
app the app was supposed to launch
um almost a year before it actually did
and basically that got to beta testing
and it was an absolute
shocker it was a shocker it was not
ready so
it and it was long story short
i got yeah wait that's the important
story this is that that's the video yeah
yeah it's yeah so it was it was an it
was
i mean uh a lesson i will never forget
and i i think i yeah i lost
lost money last time last
year's off my life it felt like but it
was
it was such a lesson so i didn't do my
due i didn't do enough enough due
diligence i went
with somebody because i was impatient
and i just
just you know thought okay well it was
actually somebody
it was actually somebody i kind of had
had a relationship
so i thought i was going to give them
the business and i felt good about
giving them
the business and but it was it was naive
on my part and i should have done
a lot more due diligence and and they
yeah didn't they didn't know what they
were doing
in the end so i had to make a decision
and start all over again
from scratch but the silv
the silver lining of that apart from the
lesson that i learned
was in the meantime i started an
instagram
and page with just before i thought the
app
the first app was about to launch and
people were so excited about the idea of
frollo and this app that
you could connect with other single
parents and organize play dates and ask
for advice
and all of this that the instagram and
page really took on a life of its own
and this community started building
there
and so what i did to kind of keep the
momentum going was people would
single parents were just messaging you
know um
saying oh you know with some asking for
some piece of advice so it might be like
you know i'm going to tell our kids
tomorrow that
you know their dad is not going to live
with us anymore does anyone have any
advice and
i'd post that anonymously to stories and
then there'd be a whole stream of stuff
so
it just kind of took off so it when the
app
was ready then in the end um
kind of ten months later there was this
a huge engaged community and there was
kind of you know two two and a half
thousand people that had signed up
for um the the waiting list on the app
itself which so there was there was two
and a half thousand
people live on the app from the day from
the day it kind of launched which
which which was really really helpful
because obviously then there's density
on the app
and there's the community that's that's
there because an app isn't gonna
feel like a good experience that there's
only two people on it you know
the day the day it launches and but yeah
so that's why in the uk in ireland
but i have to say there is definitely a
demand for it in you know everywhere
because
i get emails all the time and
you know when are you launching in
berlin when are you launching in the us
when you're launching in australia when
you know and we actually have a have a
global wait list
that's kind of constantly um yeah
getting longer so we're really keen
we're really really keen to to expand
and
you know as much as we can but we're
just kind of trying to create the right
strategy for that at the moment because
keeping the community
feeling like a kind of safe and
supported
place is the most important thing i mean
you're kind of talking about you know
two very
clashing yet interesting problems one is
you know
growing at scale which you know in
today's world is relatively easy you
just open up you know the switch and so
okay now we're open
in in other places at the same time
you're opening yourself up to all these
problems that will arise right with
curating content i mean we're saying
you know in 2020 and and since the 2016
election
we're seeing you know what happens on
social media when you don't properly
curate
not just in terms of you know the
quality of the content but the the
credibility
and the and you know the kindness behind
the content right
so and the values so so tell me a little
bit about you know
leading this product how do you how do
you envision being able to curate
you know a very safe community that is
very supportive and
not you know turning people off that are
already perhaps not you know you know
that
are going to this because they need this
emotional support in this you know
collaborative nature
definitely it's such a good question and
it's such a timely question we actually
had a
team meeting solidly about about this
area today so first of all we
so we have four values in the community
that everyone has to commit to
when they when they sign up on the app
and ultimately that's
you know be kind show empathy
share safely and you know we're we're
non-judgmental
and so they are quite vague and simple
but they cover a lot
so you know if someone is you know
you know if someone's not doing what
they they should be doing and are having
a
negative in impact on the community
those
values kind of cover it and we're pretty
strict you know we are
very quick to remove somebody if they
are not
who they say they are are not willing to
be in line with the values
right and you know people have said
and i love this that you know to them
frollo is the unicorn
of um communities or social media
because there is such
a nice supportive safe feeling as the
community gets
yeah which i love and it's so important
that you know it
it would lose its magic if that changed
and but obviously it's going to become
more and more challenging to you know
keep tabs on us so we do have
um you know a reporting system in place
in the community and i think we're
we're working on kind of making that
even
taking the automation of that even
further and creating some kind of
rules around if someone has been
reported or had you know
a certain amount of times you know
they're off and things like that and
then rewards for good
behavior as well so for those people who
are helping other people who are
creating
virtual meetups or expert content or
just you know spreading positivity in
the community
they'll be rewarded as well so we're
kind of we're looking at that but
it's it's exactly right it's like we
don't want to be like okay let everybody
in
all the countries who have single parent
like you know get in here and
cut you know it's it's really wanting to
make sure that we
that we do it in a in a considered way
i love it zoe one thing that surprised
you most
from this whole experience this whole
journey
one thing that surprised me was i'd say
how hard it is
you know i i wouldn't change it for the
world there hasn't been
you know there hasn't been a moment
where i where i've well actually that's
a lie there's probably been a couple of
moments where like
why am i what like this is relentless
you know um but no i think i think
definitely
i think people don't realize how much
work and graft
and energy you know it requires so i
think for anybody who is thinking
he's like oh i might do a startup where
i might do this i'd say unless
you are absolutely ready for it to
take over your life and unless you are
have the you know enough passion for it
don't bother
i would say i love it zoe thank you so
so much for being in the show thank you
for coming and sharing your story
i love when when people build products
because of the
of an internal issue they faced and they
explore whether you know there's other
people that face it and you've
i think correctly explore that millions
of others have it and
and are literally making their life
better by you know by by building a
product so i love that
both from the charity work to this zoe
before we leave i need three words that
you would use to describe yourself
um i would say headstrong
intuitive and
um optimistic
i love it zoe thank you very very much
stay safe and stay healthy thank you
thank you so much michael take care
lovely chatting to you
you